president Trump was wrong  to give a white nationalist  an anti-semite and a holocaust denier a  seat at the table and I think he should  apologize for it uh wow he should really  apologize for that that was the wrong  thing to do you should denounce those  individuals and their hateful rhetoric  without qualification  with that being said as I point out in  the book with that being said you know  there's other stuff I need to mention  here because well I  I don't believe Donald Trump is an  anti-semite I don't believe he's a  racist or a bigot I would not have been  his vice president if he was that's a  lie now that that that's that's where it  starts to get unbelievable